das greift mich an wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal in den game mode 04
greift es mich an und ihr seht schon
alter ich bin nahezu ich bin einfach
direkt
hallo ich meine lieben willibald ist und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft heute am freitag das
heißt ohne geheimnisvolles geräusch und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an
weil ich hab voll wenig zeit und muss
gleich los
der erste effekt wurde mir zugesendet
von niemanden weil ich habe mir gedacht
ich nehme heute mal alle facts aus dem
minecraft wiki das heißt es kann nichts
irgendwie nicht stimmen oder irgendwie
sonst was aber wenn ihr trotzdem
irgendwelche kolenfeld schreibt mir noch
gerne per mail an konkreter gmail.com
und der erste effekt ist halt aus dem
minecraft wiki forum die stars und zwar
kennt ihr eventuell reinholz das ist
entwickler und developer und der
entwickler ist das gleiche mojang ejby
mojang ist das entwicklerstudio von
minecraft und jedenfalls wurden ja mit
dem 1.8 updates diese kaninchen
hinzugefügt und die kann man ja ganz
normal ich bin hier im gaylord 0 ich
kann hier weiter da nämlich einmal
karotten und alle sind direkt sogar geld
geboten
ich hatte von 52 beispielsweise 49 also
damit kann man die züchten allerdings
kann man die auch mit löwenzahn füttern
das heißt jetzt beispielsweise 63
löwenzahn klickt ihr auf ein paar leute
mal drauf jetzt habe ich beispielsweise
noch 62 jetzt nur noch 1 60 also ich hab
schon so ein paar gefüttert jetzt nur
noch 60 gleich nur noch 59 wenn ihr noch
irgendwer 1 haben möchte möchte
irgendwelche noch jungen talenten heino
mit dir den hunger da nur noch 59 also
man kann kaninchen hier auch mit
löwenzahn füttern und zwar geht das
ganze weil ryan holz dieser entwickler
bei mojang mit dem waren ihm wohl mal
irgendwie golf spielen oder so und beim
golfspielen hat er einfach so ein wildes
kaninchen mit löwenzahn gefüttert und
deswegen haben die entwickler sich
gedacht ja man kann kaninchen jetzt
nicht nur mit karotten füttern sondern
auch mit löwenzahn walder reinholz da
die ingres kaninchen auch mal gewinnt
und bla bla bla und deswegen
funktioniert das ganze jetzt und ich
finde die jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter
hier mit löwenzahn weg nummer 2 stammt
ebenfalls aus dem minecraft wiki wer
hätte es gedacht habe ich am anfang
schon gesagt und zwar kennt ihr diese
ganz normalen kaninchen die ich wohl
noch gespannt hatte also hier irgendwie
die hier die sind jetzt hier alle grau
braun und jetzt sehen wir beispielsweise
so ein weißes dieses weiße kaninchen
sieht so ein bisschen gefährlich aus
allerdings gibt es noch ein viel
gefährlicheres kaninchen und zwar gebe
ich jetzt einfach mal
das ja ein beispielsweise sun red rabbit
99 und ihr seht schon das killer
kaninchen das sieht ein bisschen anders
aus als dieses andere sind stückchen
größer und das greift mich an wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise mal in den game
mode 0 greift es mich an und ihr seht
schon alter ich bin nahezu ich bin
einfach direktorin ich fliege jetzt mal
eben wieder hin wurde es mich getötet
hat hier so und hier sehen wir wieder
schon das killer kaninchen alter davon
muss ich meinen job machen das sieht ja
so gefährlich aus also ihr seht schon es
sieht ein bisschen anders aus als dieses
weiße kaninchen und man kann es nur bei
diesem befehl spawnen also wenn man
diese zahl dann dahinter zu 99 ändert
und bekommt man anderen hasenhaus
allerdings gibt es auch eine eins zu
1000 prozent chance also 0,1 prozent
dass man aus diesem spot also ein killer
carnitin haus bekommt und wenn ihr euch
jetzt denkt ist das jetzt ein killer
kann ich ihn oder nicht ihr seht das
schon glaube ich schon an den augen das
halt so hohe senkrechte augen und das
hat er so horizontale augen und da steht
halt auch das killer kaninchen drüber
und es greift ein auch an wenn man im
friedlich modus ist allerdings macht es
dann kein schaden
aber es greift dann innerhalb von vier
blöcken und ihr seht schon das ist
extrem stark und das war feck nummer
zwei das ist diese killer kaninchen gibt
heck nummer 3 stammt wie jeder fällt in
dieser folge auch aus dem minecraft
wickie und zwar ist dort eine anleitung
gemacht wie man ganz leicht eine
tintenfisch bzw ins eck war machen kann
und zwar würden ja diese guardians
hinzugefügt mit dem 1.8 akte der
coupierten schon so komisch an diesen
hier habe ich jetzt beispielsweise
einfach mal in so ein wasserbecken hier
gepackt also es gibt ja die möglichkeit
dass man guardians irgendwie einfängt
oder irgendwie sowas oder einfach wenn
man sport oder irgendwie so oder halt
einfach bei einem meeres tempel den
irgendwie einbaut
und wenn man ein wasserbecken hat
spawnen immer ist es egal dass es immer
so wenn man irgendwo wasser hat s bahnen
immer irgendwie tintenfische da ich
jetzt nicht lange warten möchte packe
ich dir jetzt einfach mal hier rein
so jetzt hat mich nämlich von patenten
fische drin und dieser guardian ist
natürlich gegen die tintenfische ihr
seht schon ja erzeugt einen kleinen
strahl und greift die tintenfische
anbieten fische sind natürlich friedlich
im ob sie greifen den ihnen bin ich
zurück an das heißt egal denn da drin
nicht sterben
und auch wenn er gerade irgendwie mal
ins wasser kann an ran kommen sollte der
staat nicht mehr auswahl wenn ausland
geht sondern der zappel da nur so
komisch rum
jedenfalls tötet dieser guardian jetzt
nach und nach diese tintenfische und man
könnte jetzt rein theoretisch da unten
sondern song guitar hin machen und alle
items die ihr einkommen die hier
einfallen oder so werden anhalt quasi
weggespült und in irgend so eine kiste
gelagert mit einem trichter oder so und
das sind dann quasi diese ganzen inc sex
und x6 kann man sich beispielsweise ganz
viel schwarze bolle machen das heißt
wenn ihr euch etwas ganz großes aus
schwarzer wolle machen wollt dann könnt
ihr einfach eure minecraft laufen lassen
davon guardian einsätze und der tötet
mit der zeit alle tintenfische jetzt
beispielsweise den ersten schon getötet
da würden jetzt hier 36 gefallen lassen
werden tun sollen und dann wird hier
dann in diesen wasserstrom runtergehen
die und die richtung da unten wird ahnt
richter mit einer kiste und blabla und
er tötet die jetzt hier nach der zeit da
haben wir schon wieder ein bisschen ins
heck bekommen oder einfach immer so ein
bisschen abwarten und es somit kann man
den guardian noch ganz gut ausnutzen und
jetzt sehen wir beispielsweise aus vier
von den teilen habe als 96 rausbekommen
und so kann man auf jeden fall eine in
sechs farben sehr gut herstellt viel
konnten woher will die künstlerin ist
die micro wickie und zwar sehen wir hier
schon relativ viel geld will die nicht
einfach mal angepackt habe und jetzt
sehen wir einen amboss begreift jetzt
beispielsweise einfach auf den amboss zu
ich packe jetzt eine holztafel rein und
ein verzaubertes buch und dann bekommen
wir ich habe nicht so viel erfahrung ich
habe die krise
la la la la la la la la la la wir
greifen jetzt einfach mal jetzt liegen
noch die ganzen arbeiten nur um einfach
mal drauf zu wir haben jetzt 13 level
soll das ganze reichen wenn mit einer
holztafel mit behutsamkeit 1 und zwar
laut perfekt ich lese es vor abbau
werkzeuge mit behutsamkeit verzauberung
erbringen ausschließlich kies keinen
feuerstein
ich hab hier übrigens man eine von sechs
an alle die das mal sehen wollte mir das
nicht geglaubt dass es habe also ich
kann jetzt hier soviel griffel ab und
wie ich möchte da kommen nie irgendwie
ein feuerstein raus oder ihn geschossen
dann immer noch ist aber auch kein bock
alles abzubauen
also ich mache das einfach mal nebenbei
und zwar es ist halt so ich hab euch
schon mal irgendwie in dieser folge die
glaube ich disco schafs oder diskussion
ob diskussion heißt lieber relativ am
anfang im affekt folgen die folge zehn
oder fünfzehn oder sowas um den 3
da habe ich schon gesagt wenn man eine
schaufel mit glück drei macht bekommt
man auf jedem kies drei feuerstein
heraus wenn man auf die schaufel
irgendwas mit behutsamkeit packt bekommt
man einfach nie da bekommt man nie
irgendwie vorschneider raus also packt
durch die behutsamkeit auf eine schaufel
und harke und vorstand raus kommt und
das perfekt nummer vier und es wird
langsam irgendwie dunkel weg nummer fünf
ist relativ easy er kommt aus der bei
kräftig häufig gewalt richtig aktiv
infekt zu senden so katrin jedenfalls
kann man falltüren verschieben und das
ist extrem cool weil dadurch
beispielsweise ich mach das jetzt hier
ganz kurz aufgebaut wenn man redstone
kenntnissen wir haben hier in klebrigen
kolben der zieht natürlich dieses dinge
anders geht auch mit den eisernen
falltür platte oder können wir das ganze
ding von links nach rechts 10 et cetera
und wir könnten dann beispielsweise hier
einfach mal so ein blog hinsetzen und
sieht das ganze so aus wenn man irgendwo
her laufen würde das war cool wenn man
ihn jetzt auch irgendwie so anders
gestalten könnte von einer textur aber
das wird so aussehen so wohne fällt
heute sich vielleicht versetzt und dann
kann man einfach so machen und dann ist
die falsche hier direkt darüber und man
sieht dass man hier ein geheimgang hat
und dann kann man einfach hier wieder so
machen und eines der geheimgang quasi
wieder weg und auf nun kommt auch noch
ein kolben und verbaut das ganze es ist
auf jeden fall richtig cool aber das
funktioniert nur als wenn ich hier den
block zerstöre das ganze jetzt mache
dann funktioniert das ganze nicht also
hier muss auf jeden fall einen blog dran
sein an dem sich diese platte so ein
bisschen dran festhalten kann hier das
sehen wir schon und es ist auf jeden
fall ganz coole sache und ich würde
sagen das war's dann noch mit den
heutigen minecraft wenn ihr dieses video
gerade zu ende geschaut preis ist dass
ich es geschafft habe das ganze im auto
nach hamburg noch fertig zuschneiden
irgendwie im stau oder irgend sowas weil
ich wieder in meine wohnung dort muss
und da so ein paar sachen design muss
eventuell wenn ich mir bei twitter folgt
twitter.com spannkraft und steht in der
beschreibung
poste ich daher immer so bilde wie es in
meiner wohnung bisher aussieht und
irgendwann kommt dann auch eine tour auf
meinem zweikanal luca filmt aber das
dauert alles noch ein bisschen weil ich
erst in zwei wochen umziehen und dann
würde ich sage euch gefallen hat freue
ich mich über eine bewertung wir sehen
uns im nächsten video wieder